>>Announcer Chris: Hello everyone.
Thank you for coming to today's Authors @ Google
talk.
I'm really excited to welcome Anthony Myint
and Karen Leibowitz here to talk about their
new book, Mission Street Food: Ideas and Recipes
from an Improbable Restaurant.
They've been doing some of the most interesting
and exciting things in the food scene in San
Francisco for awhile.
They're a husband and wife duo that seem to
have no lack of ambition for various restaurant
endeavors, some of which seem pretty spontaneous.
So anyways to hear about the genesis of all
these ideas, please join me in welcoming Anthony
and Karen.
[applause]
>>Karen Leibowitz: Thanks Chris and thanks
all of you for coming.
Anthony is just finishing up some final prep.
We're gonna give you some food.
We actually are here in part because someone
came to another event that we did and invited
us along and I really think this program,
Authors @ Google, is so wonderful, so thank
you so much for having us.
I guess we'll just say a little bit about
what we've been doing and give you some samples
of our book and then we'll hopefully have
a discussion.
>>Anthony Myint: Our book is split into roughly
two parts, a narrative and a food section
with recipes.
The narrative describes us a bit and then
covers our brief but eventful run in a taco
truck in 2008.
We sold flatbread sandwiches which were surprisingly
popular forcing us to move into a restaurant.
Here's a little excerpt from the narrative
of our first night in the restaurant.
>>Karen Leibowitz: Can you guys hear?
[murmurs from the audience]
>>Anthony Myint: Sorry.
So this is a little excerpt from the book
which is from the first night in the restaurant.
"As soon as we opened, orders started coming
in five or six at a time, but the metal ticket
holder was broken.
We were stacking tickets on the only available
surface in the kitchen, which was the narrow
counter where we were also plating food.
Tickets were sticking to dishes or getting
greasy and illegible.
When duplicate tickets started showing up,
disorganization turned to utter chaos.
Finally we decided to completely disregard
tickets and just make random batches of each
dish as fast as we could.
I can only imagine what the dining room must
have been like, because I never even left
the kitchen."
>>Karen Leibowitz: And I should explain that
part of our book is structured as a dialog,
so Anthony speaks and then I speak and we're
reproducing that effect for you now.
"My memories of that night are hazy.
As I sprinted the two blocks from the BART
station, I was working at the time in Berkeley,
I saw a crowd standing outside the restaurant
and wondered if they'd had to evacuate for
some reason.
I ran faster.
As I opened the door I saw a completely full
house and it seemed like everyone I knew was
there.
Half a dozen of our friends had spontaneously
stepped in to help.
It was unclear who was a server and who was
a customer and even people I didn't know seemed
familiar, like in a dream, though I probably
recognized some of them from the truck.
Then again, a lot of people in the Mission
look the same to me now that beards have come
back into fashion [audience chuckles].
The new MSF had been open for about an hour
and it was an utter shit show.
They had switched over to dim sum style service
and the tables closest to the kitchen were
gobbling up all the food, leaving the tables
farther away from the kitchen hungry and pissy."
And just as a side note, we learned after
the book went to the printer that one of our
friends who was a waitress was actually being
grabbed by the legs as she came out of the
kitchen, people wouldn't let her penetrate
farther into the dining room.
"The beer was warm, the cash register was
broken, so a friend was doling, doing all
the check calculations with pencil and paper
in the dark.
As a group we had no system, no table numbers,
no common language for the food we were serving.
We were laughably inept.
No one wanted to wash dishes full time, so
we took turns randomly going back to clean
whatever we were desperate for.
At the end of the night, I worked that dishwasher
for what seemed like hours, wondering how
I had arrived at this point in my life."
So my other job in Berkeley was as professor.
"I could hear Anthony talking with the owners
of Lung Shan behind me in Cantonese, but I
couldn't understand a word.
I thought, 'they better be talking about what
a good wife I am.'"
[laughter]
>>Karen Leibowitz: "When we got home, I was
exhausted to the point of despondency, but
I also felt a little bit sentimental.
Anthony had become a chef.
I had become a dishwasher slash restaurant
manager.
Our friends were pulling for us.
We were incompetent.
We were successful.
Nothing made any sense."
>>Anthony Myint: So I guess maybe it's worth
noting that we, we started in a taco truck
and we were selling flatbread sandwiches that
were kind of designed to make it, to take
advantage of the facilities the truck had
to offer, but they were in a sense sort of
just like gourmet tacos and before we had
even set foot in the truck for the first time,
I guess someone had blogged about it and there
was a line of customers waiting.
And then each week things got more and more
kind of crazy and we were more and more popular
and then eventually we, for reasons you can
read about in the book, were forced to move
into a restaurant.
But we only took two weeks off in that time
and we were still working full-time jobs so
we, I guess there were, there were a lot of
decisions to be made like what kind of food
we were gonna serve and who would be the staff
and would we even have table service or what?
>>Karen Leibowitz: Would anyone show up?
>>Anthony Myint: [laughing] And so.
>>Karen Leibowitz: I thought you were gonna
say a little bit about the first menu?
>>Anthony Myint: So
the first menu that we served had one of the
signature dishes from the truck, which was
called a PB&J.
It was crispy pork belly, which is the PB,
marinated jicama and cilantro aioli, among
other things, and then also a dish that was
a Burmese soup called Ohn-No-Kauk-Swe, which
I enjoyed growing up and then two kinds of
fried rice, I guess mainly centered around
smoking the rice and frying the rice in duck
fat and serving it with crispy duck skin,
which in part we're sort of trying to recreate
today with sort of like little Peking duck
hors d'oeuvres.
[pause] [inaudible]
>>Karen Leibowitz: Ok.
What?
So that flatbread sandwich kind of took many
forms over the course of Mission Street Food
and one of the most successful was kind of
a form of Peking duck with a duck breast confit
and a duck skin that had been made crispy.
So we're gonna read a little bit about the
Peking duck in our book and then also give
you a version of that, but with chicken.
So, do you wanna?
[pause]
>>Anthony Myint: "I spent a month eating my
way around China, but my favorite Peking duck
is in an old strip mall in the suburbs of
Washington D.C. at Peking Gourmet Inn.
The walls are chockablock with pictures of
politicians and celebrities, all smiling the
same Peking duck induced smile.
Ducks are carved tableside by lifelong professionals
who expertly unfurl broad swaths of crispy
skin and slices of tender meat.
The restaurant owners serve the duck with
a special variety of yellow spring onion grown
on their own farm along with hoisin sauce,
soy-cured peppers, julienned cucumbers, and
crucially, thin flour wrappers.
The entire ensemble is sublimely satisfying.
It's a dish I could eat every day."
>>Karen Leibowitz: "The traditional preparation
of Peking duck involves separating the skin
from the fat with a kind of bellows and actually
some friends of ours tried to simulate this
with a bike pump before resorting to the air
compressor at the gas station one time.
The ducks are then air dried for one or two
days to remove excess water from the skin,
then roasted by hanging over wood embers in
a brick oven so the fat can render and the
duck can self baste."
>>Anthony Myint: "Unfortunately, this was
not even remotely possible in the small refrigerators
and half-broken oven at Mission Street Food.
However, it's the crispy skin, hoisin and
cucumber combo that really brings the dish
home for me, so it's still possible to approach
that Peking duck epiphany without doing anything
the right way.
We served variations of this flavor combo
in tacos, flatbread sandwiches and even something
we called a chineedo, a rice noodle wrapped
around a Chinese donut stuffed with the usual
suspects."
>>Karen Leibowitz: So this is what that section
looks like in our book and you can see that
the recipes are given photos step by step
and then each one has a little headnote.
So you probably can't read the beginning,
but it says, "Peking duck is all about the
crispy skin, our alternative to roasting whole
ducks is to start with separate skins and
make crackling.
Ideally you'd use duck skin, but chicken skin
is easier to obtain and is a more than acceptable
substitution.
Your local butcher might be nice enough to
just give you their unwanted poultry skins,
but act quickly.
Chicken skin is the new bacon and soon opportunists
will be selling novelties like chicken wrapped
in chicken skin."
[laughter]
>>Karen Leibowitz: And then this is the next
page where you get the end of the recipe for
the Peking duck and then a kind of background
on confit and then you can see on the right
Anthony is enjoying Peking duck with an old
woman who we work with.
She'll eat anything.
It's actually kind of our game to bring her
any kind of food.
I mean it's not that Peking duck is hard to
get anyone to eat, but we have brought her
those enormous dosas or like food from all
nations and she loves it all.
So it's very gratifying to watch her eat.
>>Anthony Myint: But she likes cheeseburgers
I think the best.
[laughter]
>>Karen Leibowitz: Ok.
>>Anthony Myint: So I guess maybe now we'll
just pass out some food and things before
we move on.
[pause] So Mission Street Food was maybe one
of the earlier or first pop-up restaurants
and apart from just doing that we also kind
of had some other unusual things going on,
one of which is that we invited guest chefs
from around the city to join us and present
half of the menu each time.
Part of us doing that was because we were
working full-time jobs and it was really hard
to prep enough food for everybody, but also
part of it was that like I was just a line
cook and felt a little bit, I don't know,
I guess humble at the fact that I was now
kind of chef of a restaurant, not necessarily
having like gone through the traditional route
or having paid traditional dues and so I kind
of wanted other cooks around the city to have
that opportunity to, to come and present like
food that they were interested in making.
And so we had guest chefs serving like all
kinds of different food and then we would
just do half the menu also in the same style
as they did, so some of the kind of themes
that we, themes or styles of food that we
served over the year and a half were Malaysian
food, breakfast for dinner, Jewish food, fancy
McDonalds, chaat, whole hog, and Mexiterranean.
>>Karen Leibowitz: So when we first announced
this guest chef program, we had kind of big
ambitions.
We thought it was gonna be like a revolution
in the American restaurant kitchen, which
the kitchens tend to be pretty hierarchical,
and we were planning some kind of collaborative
style.
And so sometimes we did kind of have that
initial dream of a line cook who wanted a
chance to try out his or her own food.
Sometimes we had more established chefs who
were, you know, maybe doing California cuisine
everyday and they wanted their chance to do
something else.
Sometimes chefs would come to Mission Street
Food and do previews of restaurants that they
were opening.
So like we had Wexler's try things out and
Baker and Banker tried out their food at Mission
Street Food.
After a certain point, we did Mission Street
Food for about 20 months, and after a certain
point we kind of ran out of people who wanted
to work really hard and give away any money
that they made to charity.
[chuckles] It's weird.
[laughter]
>>Karen Leibowitz: So we were sort of left
to our own devices.
And out of that dearth of guest chefs came
this idea to do what we called the homage
series.
And it was a way of bringing in a kind of
guest chef to give the menu some focus.
So Anthony and his cronies would come up with
a chef, often one whose food they had never
actually tried, and try to make food in emulation
of that style.
>>Anthony Myint: So my cronies at that time
were Danny Bowien, who is now the chef of
a restaurant that came from Mission Street
Food sort of, called Mission Chinese Food,
and Danny has earned a lot of accolades recently
and I think he's well on his way to becoming
a celebrity chef, but at that time he was
still just a jaded line cook.
And then the other person working with me
at the time was Ian Muntzert who is now the
chef de cuisine at Commonwealth, but he had
just worked at Coi for a few months, which
is like I guess for the past few years has
been one of if not the best like haute cuisine
restaurants in the city or in San Francisco.
And so basically we had sort of too many cooks
in the kitchen and kind of a lot of different
ideas and stuff, but so we, I think Danny
actually had the idea to just make food in
the style of like world class chefs at Michelin
starred restaurants and, and there was something
you know sort of ridiculous about doing this
in a kind of run down Chinese restaurant with
Christmas lights on the walls and like loud
music and people essentially like sharing
tables huddled together in chaos in the dark
or whatever.
But over that time we did menus in the style
of Noma, which is a restaurant in Copenhagen
that has become or yeah has since gone on
to become the worlds' number one restaurant
and some other tributes like to all-time great
chefs like Escoffier but so I guess this second
thing that we'll be serving today is one of
the recipes that came from one of the homage
dinners which was a Noma tribute.
>>Karen Leibowitz: So Noma is in Copenhagen
and the idea of the restaurant is to do Nordic
cuisine, really local ingredients for Scandinavia.
Some of those ingredients are not available
to us.
So in our, in our book we give a recipe for
the oyster tarragon puree that René Redzepi
invented and the headnote says, "This is my
version of a sauce they serve at Noma, the
number one restaurant in the world.
We add oysters for depth and brininess and
to take off the, take the edge off of the
tarragon.
It's a complex sauce that could be used with
elemental dishes like steak, fish, chicken
or omelets.
I apologize to René Redzepi and his staff
as I'm sure our version doesn't do justice
to Noma's.
Serve with a musk ox tartare or wood sorrel
and juniper if you wanna bite Noma's style.
Or go off on your own if you think that you're
better than René Redzepi.
At MSF we couldn't get musk ox so we used
regular ox and AXE body spray."
[laughter]
>>Karen Leibowitz: So today we'll be serving
the oyster tarragon puree with a little bit
of mushroom and potato just as an appetizer/hors
d'oeuvre type thing.
So I hope you didn't ruin your appetite with
chicken confit.
>>Anthony Myint: One of the biggest advantages
of the homage series was giving us something
to blog about.
>>Karen Leibowitz: [chuckles] So actually
we talk a little bit about the importance
of our blog in these sections that we sort
of privately called sidebars.
So as Anthony mentioned, about half of the
book is the story of what we did and then
we have these colored pages which have sort
of particular things that we discuss.
So this one is called Blogstaurant For Better
or Worse.
>>Anthony Myint: "While the restaurant industry
has been pretty slow to adapt to the reality
of the internet age, Mission Street Food was
an early and enthusiastic adopter of new media.
In fact, we could not have survived without
the internet.
As a pop-up restaurant, we were only visible
to the public for about a dozen hours a week,
so we used our blog as a substitutes to our
front window where we could hang our little
signs announcing upcoming events, warning
that we would be closed for a wedding, or
just reminding the world that we existed.
We tried to keep it simple.
Most of our posts were just a paragraph on
the next guest chef or theme, a paragraph
on that night's charity."
I guess I forgot to mention that we donated
all of our profits to local hunger-related
charities.
"And finally the upcoming menu.
Can we all agree that we don't need any more
flash introductions, ambient electronic music
or close-up food photography before we get
to see a restaurant's address?
But the internet."
Oh, I'm sorry.
>>Karen Leibowitz: "But the internet is a
two-way street.
We had our blog and our Twitter account, but
we weren't the only ones talking about MSF.
We were a hot topic on local sites before
we sold our first flatbread and as time went
on we got more press from serious food bloggers,
who took meticulous notes on the dishes they
ate.
Their prioritization of blogging over actually
eating was, on the surface, distasteful.
But upon further consideration, we started
to see ourselves as equally responsible since
our menus were practically begging for documentation
and commentary.
Even worse, we chose our themes with an eye
toward our blog.
Yes, we were sell-outs."
>>Anthony Myint: "In our defense, we behaved
no worse than a chef pandering to local food
critics.
It just so happened that our clientèle was
largely composed of food critics democratically
selected by themselves.
Along with the food we served, we were part
of an online feedback loop of blog-driven
satisfaction and 'critical acclaim.'
Looking back, our only regret is that we spent
so much time trying to make the food taste
good rather than just crafting electronic
files replete with polished photos and pithy
remarks ready for 'consumers' to upload to
their sites.
Or perhaps we shouldn't have involved the
customers at all and simply blogged about
an imaginary restaurant ourselves.
Best of luck to any aspiring blogstaurateurs
out there.
We're looking forward to not even eating your
food."
>>Karen Leibowitz: So I guess we were thinking
that it might be interesting to sort of talk
with you guys about the effect of the internet
on the restaurant business and I guess other
kinds of culture as well.
We in some ways are blog-led to the book because
we spent so much time writing about the restaurant
that it sort of was natural to, to write further.
And I think it does sort of speak to the importance
of I guess how people organize their lives
now so that if you can sort of tap into that
in terms of the menus and the marketing and
so forth.
>>Anthony Myint: I think for us one of the
things that was pretty surprising was how
like just how pervasive and just how intense
kind of press coverage by way of the blogosphere
and stuff had gotten.
Like one point in particular that that we
mention comes to mind is I think in the second
or third week when we were operating a food
truck, a website called Eater SF, which is
like a pretty widely read and significant
media outlet.
>>Karen Leibowitz: In the food industry.
>>Anthony Myint: Right, in the food industry,
sorry.
I guess like published a piece or an update
or something about how we were gonna be serving
brownies that week instead of cookies and
then like that is pretty ridiculous, but then
later they published a crucial update saying
that the brownies would be topped with Brie,
Brie cheese and hazelnuts, and this is of
course in like San Francisco one of the major
food cities in the U.S.
>>Karen Leibowitz: But I mean so that's sort
of a more negative side of thing.
But I think on the more positive side there's
a sense that Mission Street Food, which was
a project done by people who had no funding
and in some ways no right to open a restaurant
is like a mirror image of the kind of democratization
of a lot of culture that you see with the
internet where it doesn't cost much to just
start publishing a blog or something, so I
guess we were sort of interested in that sense
of being part of a larger breaking down of
these barriers to entry for all kinds of business.
I mean in some ways we were like a startup
I guess.
But I guess from there we're just ready to
take questions if you have any.
>>male #1: I thank you so much for coming
and bringing food.
It's great.
I'm a big fan of the restaurant.
One thing I always wonder about when I'm there
is what the relationship is like between Mission
Chinese Food and Mission Street Food, in general,
like as kind of a community of people and
the Lung Shan, the people who work at Lung
Shan and how that relationship has developed
and if there was sort of any tension with
or like, how do you balance that sort of in
the kitchen, I guess?
>>Karen Leibowitz: Well maybe I'll address
part and.
So Mission Street Food was the name that we
gave this truck that we parked out on Mission
Street.
And it seemed like a clever street food thing
and then we moved into a restaurant on Mission
Street and kept the name, where it was less
accurate but it was fine.
[giggles] And we held on to that and then
changed the name to Mission Chinese Food.
And it was mostly the same people, but just
a different business model.
Mission Chinese Food is open every day, whereas
Mission Street Food was twice a week and it
has a stable menu.
So the relationship between those two restaurants
is sort of one of evolution.
The relationship between Mission Chinese Food
or Mission Street Food and Lung Shan, which
is the restaurant that we occupied is a little
more complicated.
>>Anthony Myint: So I guess we initially started
Mission Street Food just by going door to
door and kind of asking places if they would
let us use their dining room or kitchen or
let us share the space and the people at Lung
Shan were the only people who were interested.
So we started doing that and I think they
were pretty you know skeptical and curious,
but also like pretty I guess risk neutral
or risk seeking maybe even and just trying
to make a buck.
But over time I think that we sort of like
developed a mutual respect for one another
like us learning from kind of their kind of
thrift and savvy in certain ways and them
sort of respecting our like different kind
of savvy, if you can call it that.
But so, but so we operated Mission Street
Food the whole time and we were essentially
just paying them rent, although to make things
kind of on the level from a legal prospective
we had them hire us.
But now that it's Mission Chinese Food, like
we are all still employees of theirs but we
share the profits with them.
And it's been pretty, I guess pretty exciting
to kind of see how like it's like a real culture
clash or like cultural experiment or whatever
where like this business is now very much
theirs.
And like if you know if we didn't have like
their infrastructure of like kind of kitchen
staff and delivery and stuff things would
completely fall apart, like.
We definitely couldn't handle it on our own
and you know it's fun to kind of like hang
out with them in the off hours when they're
like eating watermelon and sitting around,
goofing around and like kind of grabbing each
other's asses and stuff, but.
>>Karen Leibowitz: So Anthony is functionally
the only bilingual person in the group.
So mostly people either speak English or Cantonese,
so it may be more fun for you.
[laughing]
[laughter]
>>Karen Leibowitz: But I do enjoy seeing him
make a joke in Cantonese and I can tell that
he has said something funny, even though I
can't understand it at all.
But it is really a kind of, I guess, mixed
bag.
But at this point everyone's incentives are
all lined up, so it's good.
Go ahead.
>>female #1: Ok.
Yeah, I just sort of wanted to know maybe
what was next and what you were thinking about,
like what your goal was for the book or how
you, how you kind of came about making a book
out of this experience, which I mean it definitely
seems like not necessarily your traditional
book, but where do you see, what's sort of
next on the horizon?
>>Karen Leibowitz: So should I talk about
the book and you talk about what's next?
>>Anthony Myint: Ok.
>>Karen Leibowitz: Yeah, so the book came
out of actually a friend of ours who had helped
out at Mission Street Food many times is the,
is an editor at McSweeney's and he really
let us make any kind of cookbook we wanted
and so it did seem like just an outgrowth
of the Mission Street Food project of kind
of purposefully getting in over your head
and making things up as you go along.
So that was, that was fun and I think also
the restaurant, because it was so weird, kind
of raised questions that we wanted to address
more fully, so some of those essays, like
the Blogstaurant, are a way of addressing
the things like, what is a restaurant anyway?
And in terms of actual next businesses.
>>Anthony Myint: Well, it's also worth noting
that there's some kind of silly, silliness
to start the book in the form of kind of a
fake business plan.
Which is like we never had a business plan
because things were, things kind of just grew
organically.
And then at the end there's kind of a, an
almost like manifesto of how to become a celebrity
chef, which is I think a little bit poking
fun also at kind of like celebrity chefhood
and stuff.
And I think we just wanted to write that kind
of stuff for fun.
As far as what's next, I am really heavily
involved at Mission Chinese Food, Karen, to
a slightly less extent these days, but then
we I guess will be doing the food program
at a bowling alley which will be opening in
the Mission soon.
It'll be located on 17th Street I guess near
between Shotwell and Van Ness and so we're
kind of just getting ready for that.
It figures to be technique driven comfort
food and you know I guess we're hoping to
actually make it a little bit technical and
not just put like truffle oil in macaroni
and cheese and stuff.
>>female #2: I was wondering about when you
guys design the menu at Mission Chinese, how
you kind of figure out how to balance authentic
Chinese dishes versus new technique and like
the thrice-cooked vegan bacon, how you even
think of something like that, so kind of your
approach to the design and where you want
to draw the line between authenticity and
creativity.
>>Karen Leibowitz: Yeah, well, I think there's
no system.
That's the main thing.
That's sort of how we always roll.
>>Anthony Myint: So Danny is the chef at Mission
Chinese Food, so at the very beginning he
and I worked like pretty closely on the menu.
But he has since taken over and I think the
food has gotten a lot better, but we you know
mostly he just has an idea and we kind of
work things out.
I think what, what the menu speaks towards
is definitely a complete disregard of authenticity.
Like we're happy to kind of evoke certain
dishes or resonate certain dishes or flavor
combinations that that people know and like,
but in a lot of ways I think that we use kind
of like techniques that we've learned in fine
dining, or even from other cultures.
Like Danny is an accomplished like sushi chef
and he's worked in Italian restaurants, I
think.
In, as of a couple of years ago, he was the
reigning world champion of pesto.
So I mean basically it's kind of like a different
kind of fusion where instead of just doing
like you know mango salsa or like different
ingredients, it's almost sort of like integrating
techniques and approaches from I guess from
other cultures so like a more coherent fusion
if if you will.
>>Karen Leibowitz: I think I've seen online
people debating whether it's like right to
use names like Hai nam Chicken Rice for something
that doesn't look like Hai nam Chicken Rice
in China and our feeling is basically like
it's more like modern art where you can use
a name to allude to a tradition and then break
away from it.
It doesn't have to be strict or kind of traditional
and in some ways it's more fun that way, more
individual.
It seems like you can get authentic food in
other places but you can't get like Danny's
intensely personal vision anywhere else, so
I guess we're not too concerned about authenticity.
>>Anthony Myint: Actually just really quick
on the note of Hai nam Chicken Rice, that
was funny because there was a website called
Chow Hound and there were like, there was
a long thread debating the Hai nam Chicken
Rice.
And I mean for us it was hilarious because
there were like 80 posts where people were
like just really saying harsh things and some
people were defending it.
And I mean for us it's like a almost like
an afterthought, like it's a cheap dish, that's
like seven dollars.
And you know if, if Danny wanted to make perfect
Hai nam Chicken Rice he, he easily could do
that.
But we just can't, given the circumstances
and different things.
So I guess going back to the question, a lot
of like what determines these choices in a
kitchen or menus and stuff is just the resources
available and like kind of the, the capitalist
aspects or the physical aspects, like the
practicalities.
>>Karen Leibowitz: And then we all went to
China together this summer and we had Hai
nam Chicken Rice and I definitely prefer Danny's
[laughter]
>>Karen Leibowitz: And I mean I know that
I don't have a lot of credibility, but on
the other hand if you like eating it, what's
so wrong with that, you know?
But people can get very worked up about it.
>>female #3: That's close to what I was going
to ask.
The restaurant was closed over the holidays
because I understand everybody went back to
China.
Was it, did you both go on that trip and can
you talk a little bit about the experience?
>>Karen Leibowitz: Yeah, you can.
>>Anthony Myint: So we went to China where
the owners live, it's actually in a small
town called Lung Shan and them.
We went there with the owners and their children
and a few of the cooks and the children were
the only Americans anyone in that town had
ever seen before us.
So I think that makes Karen the only Caucasian
to ever visit Lung Shan proper.
But it was a, I think, a great cultural experience
for us because they kind of came back in style
with a lot of, well I guess it's almost like
a family reunion when they go back, and so
the owner's brothers live nearby.
So they all kind of came back from different
areas and they had a big banquet kind of in
the town square and they bought hundreds of
dollars of extremely dangerous fireworks and
kind of launched all these things and it was,
it was pretty exciting.
>>Karen Leibowitz: Yeah, it was, it was really
wonderful for us to see where they came from.
This was the man's hometown and his mother
was in her 80s and about this tall and held
my hand through the whole fireworks situation.
We were both a little freaked out.
And it was also interesting in terms of food,
because you know a lot of times in California
people talk about local and sustainable and
so forth, but when we arrived in the town,
they all went in to the garden and you know
grabbed some chickens and picked a lot of
vegetables and actually jumped in the pond
and fished for that night's dinner.
I mean it was as local as possible, it was
about ten feet away from where we ate.
And their whole method of fishing was pretty
interesting because two brothers would get
in the pond and two brothers were on the side
and they had this giant net and they hit the
water so that the fish would jump into the
net and it felt like we could have been in
any year in the last thousand years.
You know it was so I don't know it was a completely
different world from where we were normally
cooking together.
And then we ate out on this courtyard and
everybody sort of cleaned up together and
it was, it was really amazing.
And I think it made some of the tensions that
we might feel in the restaurant a little bit
muted, just to see where they were coming
from.
Christine?
>>Female #4: I wanted to talk about the charitable
aspect of everything that you guys are doing.
How difficult is it first of all, how sustainable
is that to make that commitment to charitable
giving and additionally do you see that sort
of model progressing?
Like do you see other restaurants kind of
moving to that, do you see any kind of trend
in that?
And where might, where in other cities might
we see that sort of thing?
>>Karen Leibowitz: I'll just say a little.
So when we first started Mission Street Food,
we took a small salary for ourselves, I think
we each took $400 a week and then everything
that we made beyond that we gave to charities
that fed the hungry.
These days Mission Chinese Food has really
focused on the food bank because as we got
to know more about the food delivery system
in the city we saw that as really the most
efficient way to make a difference.
So 75 cents from every entrée at Mission
Chinese Food goes to the food bank.
And then at our other restaurant, Commonwealth,
$10 from every tasting menu goes to a charity,
and that rotates every month in a kind of
haphazard way.
It'll be different issues, not necessarily
hunger.
>>Anthony Myint: Well so I guess charitable
restaurants is sort of what got me into the
food business to begin with and I had always
imagined trying to open a place that was kind
of like completely scalable like Chipotle
or something but just with a small charitable
aspect.
And when Mission Street Food started to become
very popular, we basically just thought why
not start now, so it was never our intention
really to do it that way, but things just
kind of progressed that way.
And I guess as far as sustainability, I mean
so far it feels sustainable.
It's hard to say whether the charity actually
drives business or whether it like creates
a predisposition for, you know, like a customer
to be like more receptive to it or not, but,
you know, so far I guess since those restaurants
have opened like just over a year ago in total
I think the two have raised over $100,000
for charity, so that I think there's like
a lot of room for you know sustainability
there.
>>female #5: Thank you guys for making the
trek down to Google
>>Karen Leibowitz: Oh, our pleasure.
>>female #5: during rush hour nonetheless.
Can you talk about your inspiration or where
did you learn how to cook?
Where did this all come from?
>>Anthony Myint: I guess I probably first
sort of learned how to cook growing up just
'cause both my parents worked and my grandmother
lived with us.
And she didn't speak English very well, so
she watched a lot of cooking shows and I kind
of just watched them with her.
And I guess since then my first fine dining
job was at a restaurant in the Mission called
Bar Tartine.
And they went through a lot of different chefs
early on, but then they kind of settled on
a really great chef named Jason Fox.
And I feel like I learned a lot from various
people, but I probably learned the most from
him and then also a lot from Danny Bowien,
who I work really closely with now.
>>Karen Leibowitz: Yeah, I think that cooking
school is overrated and so if anyone you know
is considering going, tell them not to.
Yeah, Chris.
>>Announcer/Chris: Thanks again for coming,
so on the one hand you guys embrace a lot
of sort of internet things like blogging and
Twitter and that sort of thing, but on the
other you're working with McSweeney's, whose
food writing of late has been this not so
much, I guess very offline, very long food
editorials, lots of photos and always on paper,
so in a sense I think it's unfair to call
them Luddites, but they're very much kind
of more traditionalists when it comes to books,
so could you talk a little bit about working
with them and the kind of decisions that led
to doing the book the way you did it?
>>Karen Leibowitz: Sure.
You know I think that McSweeney's as a publisher
certainly loves paper, but they're actually
doing some interesting things online as well
and originally we were kind of thinking of
doing something more as an app, and that could
still happen.
I think that cookbooks are definitely ripe
for that kind of innovation.
A lot of what we were doing was trying to
break out of the mold of traditional cookbooks,
so there's a kind of tradition or even cliché
of like a little headnote that says "I was
traveling in Portugal and I met an old woman
and she taught me this sauce" or something
and then the recipe and then a finished dish
photo and we definitely didn't want to do
that.
So a lot of our finished dish photos are almost
like jokes about finished dish photos.
Like the pork belly dish is sitting on top
of a stack of diet books.
[chuckles] Just because we sort of didn't
want to do it that way and McSweeney's definitely
encouraged us to do that.
I think what they want to do in general is
sort of push the boundaries of genres whatever
that is and so they do really interesting
things with paper to show how far you can
go with paper and I think that there's something
similar with the cookbooks.
They're also, their offices are located kind
of around the corner from Mission Street Food,
so it was also just extremely convenient.
[pause]
>>Anthony Myint: To me also I feel like I've
read a lot of cookbooks and the part that's
the most interesting, just for me personally,
is like learning more about the people or
whatever like the story of the place.
I mean certainly sometimes I really want the
recipe or whatever, but these days you can
pretty much like find every recipe online
anyway.
>>Karen Leibowitz: Right.
So we emphasized the narrative a bit more.
Yeah.
>>female #6: What is your favorite restaurant
in San Francisco besides your own and your
favorite dish at Mission Chinese?
>>Karen Leibowitz: What's our favorite restaurant?
>>Anthony Myint: Well, we have a lot of like
budget favorites, but I think currently my
favorite restaurant that I'm not involved
in at all is Atelier Crenn, I think the chef
there is really going for it you know in an
extremely elaborate and fanciful way that
I think some people think is kind of silly
or extraneous and I think is like very worthwhile
even though it's somewhat extraneous, but
the food is also really delicious.
>>Karen Leibowitz: We went there once, it
was definitely expensive, but very comfortable
as an experience, the, it's one of those things
where the service is so good that it stops
being formal and starts being relaxed in a
way like everyone sort of anticipating your
needs perfectly, but the food was as Anthony
said a bit fanciful, but kind of delightful,
like you almost felt like you wanted to laugh
when you put it in your mouth.
So it's a little bit embarrassing to say that
you know this restaurant that we've only been
to once is our favorite restaurant, but that
definitely made a big impression.
We also, we live in the Mission, and we eat
a lot of burritos and I guess [giggles] we
also tend to like going to places where we're
friends with the chef and so this process
of having guest chefs was great because you
can go and people you know you worked with
them and then they are very nice when you
come in.
[laughing]
[pause]
>>Anthony Myint: I guess also Vietnamese food.
>>Karen Leibowitz: Yeah.
>>female #7: Where?
>>Karen Leibowitz: Where?
>>Anthony Myint: I don't know.
I like a place in the Sunset called PPQ.
>>Karen Leibowitz: On Irving near 19th.
We also go to the Tenderloin for, at Turtle
Tower a lot.
They have a new outlet in Soma, which is kind
of exciting.
[pause]
>>Anthony Myint: And I eat the food at Mission
Chinese Food far too often, so my favorites
vary from day to day.
>>Karen Leibowitz: I feel like we're always
most excited about whatever is new.
Like the new thing comes on and I'll eat that
kind of without cease until the next thing
comes.
But I think that probably the thrice-cooked
bacon might be my standby or the tiger salad.
[pause] But in normal life I think we spend
a lot of time trying to eat vegetables just
to catch up.
[laughter]
>>Announcer/Chris: So yeah, I guess we're
at time.
Thanks again for coming.
>>Karen Leibowitz: Thank you.
>>Anthony Myint: Thanks.
[applause]